ever been bothered by an ultra slow
download how about a phone that won't
stay charged or a cracked touchscreen
imagine you were stranded on an island
with nothing to drink what if science
came up with a way to solve all these
problems with a single chemical compound
that you can find of all places in a
pencil a thousand gigabytes in one
second a smartphone fully charged in
five super thin flexible and unbreakable
touchscreens and a personal salt water
filter all this and more is possible
with the Nobel Prize winning material
graphene as early as the 1940s
theoretical studies predicted graphene
to have high levels of electrical
conductivity thermal conductivity and
breakage strength graphene was also
known to compose the subunits of the
common material graphite found in a
pencil draw a line and groups of
graphene flakes slide onto the paper
producing a mark the problem was that no
one could figure out how to isolate a
single flake scientists tried various
chemical means resulting in nothing more
than graph it expunged mechanical
polishing got them to a thousandth of a
millimeter of graphite but that was
still about 1,000 layers of graphene in
2002 a group from the University of
Manchester took a more MacGyver approach
using their self dubbed scotch tape
method physicists or Andre gaim and Sir
Konstantin Novoselov peeled away at a
graphite crystal producing flakes that
became vanishingly thin an atomic force
microscope revealed their success
the elusive material finally in hand
scientists were able to see just what
graphene could do as predicted it's an
excellent electrical conductor the free
electron on each carbon atom and
graphene enables movement of charge
across the surface moreover its thermal
conductivity or ability to transfer heat
is higher than that of copper
mechanically the strong bonds between
carbon atoms and the inherent stability
of an X agonal array combined to produce
the strongest material known to man
nonetheless the bonds of graphene
retained remarkable flexibility as a
sprayable two-dimensional surface it can
used to easily tune the properties of
other compounds a lot of people are
excited about graphene's possible
versatile applications because graphene
has very high conductivity and is almost
completely transparent it could be used
to make more efficient electronics these
electronics have the potential to be
more environmentally safe once graphene
extraction techniques are improved with
its high breakage strength graphene
could be the key to lighter and stronger
building materials new techniques for
creating nanoscale pores in sheets of
graphene indicate that it could be used
to make ultra-thin filters as scientists
think of new ways to use this super
material it's worth recalling its humble
entry into the scientific world using a
piece of scotch tape and a block of
pencil led to scientists were able to
make a groundbreaking discovery in 2010
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
awarded Guymon novoselov the Nobel Prize
in Physics for their efforts together
they proved that scientific innovation
does not always require fancy
instrumentation it requires persistence
and creativity
you